hello my name is Karen Gordon will fill
courage the radio show her hair with
filmmaker are teacups and we just had
the pleasure of speaking with him about
Lovelace and Los Angeles as well as
Chloe and he's sweating so Archie this
is your fourth project that we're coming
up on we're curious what you've learned
from your prior three that you're now
applying to your fourth project well
first of all the name of the project is
called the trailer parking okay and it's
a script that I've been working on for
several years and aside from the first
three where I basically wrote films and
just wanted to I cast it based on a few
things one of which being what we could
afford of course another was was it was
more about the axis of people like you
get what I really want to do with this
fourth fourth film is get to a list
actors attached in work in the last
three well one of them was a documentary
so it really wasn't about the casting or
the any main people but I really found
dealing with distributors and most
people when you're trying to get a film
out there you need to have name
recognition levels Los Angeles had dash
mihok and brittany daniel who are named
actors and their incredible actors but
when they keep people here those names
are like oh um yeah how do i know them
like they know the name but it's not
like you know Oh Brad Pitt you know like
a name that that if you say the name
people know the actor and so I'm really
committed Dennis Anderson who's my
producer we're really committed to
finding two solid alias actors we've
really feel that the material is
something that they could relate to and
it really gives it its it's they're
going to want to do it because of the
project because they're two characters
that they normally may not get to play
if they're in blockbuster films it's
certainly not like a blockbuster type
movie it's it's a coming-of-age indie
film I guess you know in
sort of compare it to like a little miss
sunshine in some way although it's
totally its home is completely different
but where I'm really concentrating the
budget is much more like la vez los
angeles which is a five hundred thousand
dollar budget clunky sweating which was
a minuscule budget I mean really came in
hard costs for around fifty thousand
dollars but with deferred payments and
so forth it was a little bit more than
that but this project is being budgeted
at four million and a lot of that of
course is taking into consideration the
fact that we want to a list actors
attached to it so hindsight being
twenty-twenty what would you never do
again that's you that you did with your
prior three projects what are some
mistakes that you just swear you'll
never make again well this looks like
basically the AOS actors I would never
do a movie that has no named actors in
it because i know i should not say that
I for my next film I don't want to do
that because I've already got through
the experience of making any films that
with no name actors I want to see my
next movie get to a next level where
it's released theatrically it could be a
small Fiat release that's really just
set up as a platform for DVD I'm fine
with that but I've never had a movie
that's been released theatrically so
that's my next goal and the only way to
really achieve that I mean obviously
there's plenty of exceptions to the rule
you know like Magna Pauline dynamite or
paranormal activity I mean these are
deaf but they are the exceptions to the
rule and for the most part you know in
order to get a film theatrical release
you need to have talent attached to it
what are the problems I have with levels
Los Angeles is a romantic comedy it's
impossible to get a romantic comedy
release if you don't have big name
actors it just is because the idea
itself is people love to romantic
comedies but they love to see you know
Julia Roberts and romantic comedy George
Clooney and you know they don't
necessarily want to see no name actors
romantic comedy again it can be done I'm
not trying to discourage anyone at all i
think if you know do what you're doing
and go after your dreams but for me
personally I want to try to take this
Avenue as far as getting a list talent
attached
music